las demostraciones mundiales en apoyo a
las mujeres iraníes no dan tregua los
carteles con el rostro de maxa Mini la
joven de 22 años asesinada bajo custodia
de la policía de la moral y de anís han
inundado las calles de decenas de
ciudades estamos aquí Para apoyar a la
iraníes por sacrificar sus vidas para
conseguir sus derechos humanos estamos
aquí para apoyarlos no están solas la
diáspora iraní y las activistas en el
exilio se han alzado como la voz de
aquellas mujeres que protestan en su
país bajo la fuerte represión de las
autoridades de la República islámica han
quitado internet no podemos estar en
contacto con nuestro familiar en Irán
estamos haciendo ese manifestación para
ser voz de la gente que están en la
calle en Irán para ser voz de la gente a
iraní vos el pueblo iraní por eso
estamos aquí las protestas ya han
entrado en su tercera semana dentro de
la nación persa
ahora mismo ha muerto mucha gente del
país están en las calles y solo quieren
libertad Eso es todo y estamos aquí para
ayudarles solo queremos ayudar pedimos
ser nuestra voz pedimos ser pedimos
ayuda porque simplemente no queremos
este régimen de Irán casting
la reivindicaciones se extendieron Más
allá de la obligatoriedad de lijar con
las jóvenes iraníes pidiendo la caída
del régimen
exigimos Libertad Libertad de elección
libertad de vivir porque nos han
restringido todo es contra los derechos
humanos y ahora más
pasta Chucho Todo comenzó con la
protesta del velo pero todos sabemos que
la demanda va más allá con este régimen
no es posible recibir Derechos Humanos
[Música]
las organizaciones de derechos humanos
alarman de que casi un centenar de
personas habrían muerto en las
manifestaciones y miles más habrían sido
detenidos por las fuerzas de seguridad